the Dinobots are one of the most
intriguing yet least known of all the
transformer types in the movies and the
animated flicks so in this video we
shall dive in a bit into the origins of
these Dinobots and also showcase to you
the tendyne Abbas that appeared and
should have appeared in Michael Bay's
transformer series so the origins of the
main Dinobots are still a mystery in the
movie timeline in the Marvel Comics
continuity the Dinobots in the Marvel
Comics were not created on earth as in
the cartoon but were distinct and
pre-existing unit of five Autobot
soldiers who were bought the Ark when it
crashed to earth in yet another timeline
the discovery of fossilized dinosaur in
their volcano base said the Autobots on
the track to creating the Dinobots
Wheeljack and ratchet created 310 watts
and one of them being Grimlock but in
the movie timeline they were trophies
that were collected by the most
dangerous bounty hunter called knocked
down but their designs when transformed
a reminiscent of planet Earth's ancient
dinosaurs notably the t-rex the
Triceratops a two-headed pterosaur and a
spinosaur could they have been created
millions of years ago when they were
harvesting transformium that were
created during the Cretaceous extinction
event probably so but then again a
Spinosaurus was probably extinct by that
time so as we can see they might have
been created based on the fossils of
these dinosaurs anyway here are the
Dinobots let's start with slash slash is
a Dinobot who was supposed to appear in
transformers age of extinction he is a
skilled hunter and is capable of stealth
due to his small size equipment cyber
sites in robot mode and claws as a
velociraptor slash shares his
engineering with one step change a
Grimlock but the two are different modes
Raptor Dinobots were at one stage
planned to appear in the age of
extinction film with concept art
depicting a large number of them
charging into Hong Kong alongside scorn
he is the smallest of the mature
Dinobots the second one sloth is a
member of the Dinobots proposed to
should have appeared in transformers age
of extinction but didn't due to his
small head as compared to the body slope
is categorized as being dumb really dumb
but it actually proves strategic as all
his brain cells have been traded to pure
robot muscle he can take out any
opponent provider that any of the other
Dinobots can point out the right way as
he is a warrior from Cybertron's ancient
past who transforms into a robotic
Apatosaurus his robot mode resembles a
rather chubby Knight and armed with a
pair of powerful Lance's the third one's
null is one of the most uniquely weird
designs it's not as one of the Dinobots
who should have been seen or should have
appeared in transformers age of
extinction his robot mode resembles a
spiky Arthurian Knight Snell hates
everybody
he hates Dinobots he hates the Autobots
he is Decepticons so basically he hates
everything in sight he transforms into a
gigantic monstrous robotic stinger soros
snarl also appears to have the same
personality aspect of hating everything
and everyone as bone crusher big and
brutish and around the same size as the
Triceratops slug so let us shift our
attention to the tiny ones sometime
after the age of extinction after the
untimely and surprising departure of
Optimus Prime and the defeat of lockdown
the Dinobots were joined by adorable
bundles of death known as the mini
Dinobots this group of cute yet
extremely deadly baby robots are sharp T
Terry and tops they are the newest
generation of Dinobots designed after
Grimlock sloth and strafe the origins
are hazy as transformers cannot
reproduce and the only sources of
Energon are lost but they might have
been created by Cade Yeager using
transformium
the first one sharp T or also known as
mini Grimlock was born at some point
during
knockdowns death and Optimus Prime's
departure from Earth due to his small
size sharp T was allowed to reign freely
in the jungle premises and often would
hang out with Katie agus personal
trailer not listening to any command
when day trader arrived drift was seen
toying with sharp T on his son the
second one Terry also known as mini
strafe is the pint-sized flying for
simile of strafe and the movie Terry was
seen to brought adrift during one of his
meditative balancing
by resting on his foot when Kate
returned to his trailer he asked Terry
to fetch some beer from him from the
fridge a trick which Terry was still
trying to perfect terry was later
present when day trader gifted the
Autobots who the night ship another one
is called tops also known as mini [ __ ]
he is the diminutive yet dangerous
doppelganger of the dangerous and
powerful Dinobots lug tops was born at
some point following lockdowns death and
Optimus Prime's departure from Earth the
same with the other ones when Kate
returned to his trailer he found tops
wrecking habit in Australia and I would
say he is the cutest of the three now
comes the four main ones from the age of
extinction the first one Grimlock
Grimlock is usually portrayed as the
leader of the Dinobots in the Michael
Bay's universe
Grimlock is an ancient and powerful
warrior who takes the form of a
Tyrannosaurus Rex from Earth standing at
84 feet tall he is the leader and the
mightiest Dinobots after all he values
power and strength / wisdom and
compassion while on lockdown ship
Grimlock was seen briefly when locked
down was imprisoning and talking to
Optimus Prime it was later revealed by
lockdown that this place is too prison
for the legendary Knights as one of the
most powerful warriors alive his general
approach to a problem is to smash it
first and worry about the specifics
later the second one strafe strafe is
one of the Dinobots who appeared in
transformers age of extinction he is 57
feet tall and he could take the form of
a pterosaur like his fellow Dinobots his
robot mode
does the form of an Arthurian Knight
unlike the other Dinobots however strafe
outside of battle is rather calm gentle
and friendly even to humans strafe was
among the Dinobots freed from lockdown
ship and subsequently yielded to Optimus
Prime's command during the battle in
Hong Kong strafe aided bumblebee as he
balanced stinger and later on strafe got
to munch on stingers head the third one
slug slug is one of the Dinobots who
appeared in age of extinction
he is 71 feet tall he can take the form
of what appears to be a triceratops
the only orders he will take other ones
that involve fighting and or killing
Decepticons and refuses to take any
other orders otherwise making him very
stubborn and hot-headed his row
what more resembles a night with a
jousting helmet though he initially had
to be held back by Grimlock slopped he
lured to Optimus Prime's charge when
Grimlock was bested in combat slug
allowed drift to write him into battle
where Slavs ferocity and durability
proved a great asset against galvatron's
forces and the last one is called scone
scone also known as spike is a member of
the Dinobots and appeared in age of
extinction he has the largest Dinobot at
87 feet tall he can take the form of
what appears to be a Spinosaurus he is
the demolitions expert and the most
intelligent of the Dinobots his robot
mode resembles a knight with a tail
forming the powerful spear first right
hand while the head becomes a garnet of
his left in age of extinction scorn
allow crosshairs to write him into
battle in Hong Kong where scorns massive
size and lethal sail Spike's proved a
great asset in turning the tide against
the battle against galvatron's forces
and with that we come to the end of the
video about the Dinobots be sure to
subscribe and share this channeling to
your friends